[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, hello everybody.
And welcome to another Chrome
Apps Office Hours.
Today I'm joined by Mike Tsao,
who is joining me from
Mountain View.
Mike, do you want to
introduce yourself?
MIKE TSAO: Sure.
Thanks, Pete.
Hi.
My name's Mike Tsao.
I'm an engineer on the Chrome
Apps and Notifications team,
and I'm working on
notifications.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
So Mike's joining us today,
because he's been one of the
main guys who's been building
the new rich notification
system for Chrome apps.
If you've played with the WebKit
notifications or the
HTML5 notifications before in
Chrome and in other browsers,
you're somewhat familiar with
some of the notification stuff
that's available.
But the new notification system
really allows you to
provide much richer and, I
think, much more beautiful
notifications within
your application.
If we can switch over to my
screen for a sec so we can
have a look at a couple
of these.
So there's four different types
of notifications that
are available to users or
to you as a developer.
There's the basic notification,
which is just
simply an image and some text.
There's a simple notification,
which is, again, an
image and some text.
You can provide a little
bit more text on that.
And you can also provide
buttons.
I don't have any buttons shown
on the sample that I have on
screen right now.
The third type is an
image notification.
So you can pop up an image, so
that you can provide, hey,
maybe somebody has
added new photos.
You can think something similar
to what Google+ does
on an Android phone.
When there's a new image,
you see that
little bit of the image.
And finally, the fourth type
of notification is a list
notification.
This is really great for if
you have a whole bunch of
things that you need to tell the
user about, but you don't
want to put them all into
five or six different
notifications.
You can go in and put in
five different types.
And with the simple, the
image, and the list
notification, those
are all available.
You can add buttons to each of
those so that the user can
interact with each of those.
Right now, this stuff is under
the experimental API, but
that's changing.
Mike, you said you pushed
some of that stuff in
earlier this week.
So it should be going away?
MIKE TSAO: Yeah.
We have a change list that's
in flight right now that's
going to be taking us out of
experimental and into dev
channel only.
And what that means is that now
it'll be easier for you to
distribute your extension or
app to users who are on the
dev channel without making them
go through the hassle of
turning on the experimental
flag.
PETE LEPAGE: Perfect.
So once that goes away,
that's going to make
things a lot easier.
The demo that I'm going to show
you today, I'm running it
in Chromium.
Because right now this
only works on
Chrome OS and on Windows.
It's not available quite yet
on Mac, but it is coming.
It's something we're working on,
so we expect to see that
land in the near future.
So the rich notification
API, it's
chrome.notification.create.
And there's three parameters
it takes.
An ID, so that on any of the
callbacks, you know which
notification showed up.
There's options, which we'll
talk about in a sec, and
creation Callback, so the
callback that gets called once
the notification has shown up.
The object that you pass for
the notifications takes a
couple of different things.
So it takes the template type.
And all of this stuff is not
in the documentation yet.
We're a little bit ahead of
the documentation on this,
which I always think
is kind of fun.
So you can find some stuff here
as well, we'll put up in
a minute or two.
There's a blog post with
a little bit more.
So template type takes either
basic, simple, image, or list,
depending on what type of
notification you want to show,
the title, the message.
In some cases, you can have the
expanded message, which is
going to show up on the basic
notification, I believe.
The image URL.
So if you're going to have that
image pop up, you want to
provide the image URL
so it knows where to
grab the image from.
And if you're going to have a
list that items takes in an
array with the list of things
that you want to show up.
So it takes title and message.
You can also--
MIKE TSAO: One more thing
I'd like to point
out, Pete, if I may?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, absolutely.
MIKE TSAO: If you're using the
icon URL fields, then for a
packaged app, you're going to be
subject to content security
policy, CSP, versus if you're
using it in an extension, the
CSP is pretty lax there.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
OK.
MIKE TSAO: One slightly
surprising behavior might be
that you're not able to just
head off to the open web and
grab an image from there to
display in your notifications.
So be aware of CSP for packaged
apps, and try to
avoid being surprised by that.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
That's a really good point.
In fact, in the demo we'll show
in a sec, we've handled
that where the images
are there locally.
And I'll show you how we
did that in a sec.
And then there's a set of rich
notification events that you
can have as well.
So that when the notification is
shown, when it's closed, if
it's clicked, or if the user
clicks on a button, obviously,
you need to have a callback so
that you can handle each of
those particular things.
So with that, let's pop out of
here, and let's go have a look
at a real, live demo.
Lovely.
I always love it
when my virtual
machine locks up on me.
There we go.
All right.
So here we go.
I've got this running.
Like I said, it only
runs in Windows and
Chrome OS right now.
And unfortunately, I don't have
a Chrome OS set up in
canary or dev, but I'll get that
going hopefully in the
near future.
This notification--
if we can pop up the URL for the
sample app right now, this
is in the Chrome app sample.
So you can go and grab
this from the URL.
So the first letter there, that
says a zero, not an O. So
it's O, capital U--
Sorry.
Zero, capital U, small N,
capital U, capital V.
Somewhere that way.
Yeah.
Anyways, so here we go.
We've got this app.
If I click on this button, it's
going to show a simple
notification.
So sure enough, there's the
simple notification.
And you can see that
it's a simple
notification, just some text.
If I close this guy--
click on Close.
And instead of having a mail
icon, I want an Africa icon.
We can change the icon, the
image that shows up there, to
be whatever you want.
This app just has a couple of
predefined ones set up here.
Image notification.
You can see here we've got
a nice, big size image.
We've got the title.
You've got the text below it.
And a list notification.
So it shows up with
all of the things.
I'll close this guy, and
I'll add a button.
Show a photo on G+.
So for example, I
could do this.
And sure enough, when the user
clicks on that, the event gets
called and you can open up
a window to whichever
application that you
want to happen.
So let's take a look
at the code for
how this guy is written.
And I'll bring up Sublime and
have a look at my main JS.
So one thing I want
to point out.
All of the code for this
application was written in the
actual app JavaScript file.
But I think in a real
application, you're probably
not going to want to do that.
You're probably going to want to
put the notification events
and notification handlers and
all that kind of stuff into
the app JS or into
the main JS file.
And the reason why I say that
is because if you want a
notification to pop up, you
probably want the notification
to pop up when the application
maybe isn't running, when
certain events happen.
Or if the app is already
running, the user's already
probably in it and using it.
But you want to be able to pop
those notifications up even if
the user's not running
the application.
So by putting the events and the
handlers into your main JS
file, you can listen for alarms,
you can put some of
your background processing
script in there.
So that way, things are running
as you'd expect.
So let's have a quick peek at
what's going on in this
application.
So the way that we wrote this
here is all of the images that
are possible that you can have
in the array list, so as you
pop up that particular
notification.
We've got that.
And then in this particular
case, just because we wanted
to be able to show the
different types of
notifications, we created a set
of objects that have each
of the different
set of options.
You can see here, here's the
list with title list
notification, a message, and
then each of the list items.
And then we add our
Event Listeners.
So go in.
On our page load, we say,
Chrome experimental
notification on display.
Add Listener.
And our callback is the
notification displayed.
So when the user runs this, we
call the Do Notify event.
So on any of the clicks to any
of the events, we go in,
figure out which element or
which button they clicked on.
Now, we talked about-- and Mike
mentioned this earlier.
Making sure that your image
comes from your local file
system, so that you're not hit
by any of the CSP things.
So here in our image URL, we
say, chrome.runtime.geturl.
And we provide the URL to
the particular image.
So that way, it's going
to give us that
fully-qualified URL.
So that way, when it goes to
grab that image, we pull it
from our local file system.
We're all good to go.
We don't have to worry about,
hey, where did that image come
from, what are the CSP rules.
We know that we're getting the
image from the right place.
And then finally, on our
options.button, we can go in
and say, buttons and push the
two buttons into the array
lists if there are
two buttons.
Or maybe we only just
need one button.
And then finally,
chrome.notifcation.create.
In this particular case, we're
just using a simple ID based
on the number.
But you can use whatever
you want in here.
We pass it our options and
our create Callback.
So it's a pretty simple thing
to go and create these
notifications.
We've got our callback
handlers that
show each of the events.
So actually, I'm going to
pop back over to our
sample here for a sec.
And if I go in and Inspect
Element, so that we can see
what's happening in the console,
you can see all of
the different events that
happened in here.
And we can see, oh, notification
ID was closed.
Notification ID1 was displayed
to the user.
So if I add an image
notification and I click on
this button, if we go down
here to the very bottom,
notification ID14 was
successfully created and our
notification button
0 was clicked.
So it's a relatively easy way
to be able to go and pop up
notifications and tell
the user about things
that are going on.
So we just put up on screen
the link to questions.
So if you have questions about
these notifications or how you
can use these notifications in
your app or where to expect
these, go post your questions
in Moderator, and we'll take
them here in just about
two minutes or so.
So like I said, getting
this to run is a
relatively simple process.
There are, I believe--
Let's just double-check
on this.
I don't believe you need--
Actually, maybe Mike, you
can tell me while I
try to look it up.
Does the application need any
particular permissions to be
able to use these?
MIKE TSAO: Yes.
At this moment, you're going
to need the experimental
permission, because it's
an experimental API.
When we leave experimental,
it's going to require the
notification permission.
And this is not a very noisy
permission in the sense that
it's the kind of thing that will
scare away your users.
It's pretty straightforward
stuff, but you will need that.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
All right.
Well, let's pop over
to questions.
If we can bring the question
URL back up.
It looks like I have lost my
internet connection, which is
always a little bit of fun.
Oh, there we go.
All right.
So you can post your
questions in there.
There are no questions
yet, but that's OK.
One of the things that I think
is really exciting about this
is it really does provide an
easy way for developers to be
able to alert people about stuff
that's going on within
their apps.
And your apps don't necessarily
always have to be running.
If you put the handler for this
inside the main JS file
or inside your background script
and you handle things
like maybe you're listening for
new data that gets posted
to a server.
Maybe you're using the Alarms
API and you want to pop a
notification up that reminds the
user that, hey, it's maybe
time to take your medication
or hey, you haven't been to
the gym today, you should
go to the gym.
That would be a great little
thing that Fit Better, any of
those fitness applications
went in and used.
So I think with that, it looks
like there aren't too many
questions today.
So Mike, do you have anything
that you want to add?
MIKE TSAO: Well, we're really
excited about this API.
And particularly visually, it's
turned out really nicely.
And we're happy about that.
And it's a super simple
API to use.
We're going to be adding more
templates in the future to
cover different use cases.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, awesome.
MIKE TSAO: So now is really the
time for people to get in
there and give it a try and make
sure that we've covered
every use case that
we can think of.
If there is a particular
template or layout that you're
really wanting, then this is a
great time to suggest that.
And we'll get our UX and UI
folks working on it to make it
look gorgeous for you.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
That's great.
So for those of you who do want
your own templates and
want to provide, go file a bug
on CR Bug, Chromium Bugs.
And let us know about
it, so that we know.
And then get your friends to
go and star those bugs, so
that we see that there's
a lot of community
interest behind that.
Cool.
Well, Mike, thanks
for joining me.
I know it's a little bit early
for you, so thanks for coming
in early and joining
us and talking a
little bit about this.
And thanks, everybody,
for tuning in.
We'll be back next week,
Tuesday, at our
regular time and place.
Thanks, guys.
MIKE TSAO: Thanks, Pete.
[MUSIC PLAYING]